[Music]
jessica in little rock arkansas
how are you jessica i'm good how are you
guys
better than we deserve what's up good
well um let me tell you i know how
ignorant i am in all of this so go easy
on me here and i called on the perfect
date with anthony being there
um so i am the person in my family to
have gone to college
went got a full ride for undergrad and
then for vets so i said yeah let's take
out all the student loans
so fast forward seven years later i now
have 394 000
in student loans so um
loan forgiveness the whole 20 years you
know you hear that myth
um decided i'm not going to do that
we're going to bust down and try to
get these i think i can get them in
three to four years what do you do
i i'm a veterinarian good
yes sir yep just started in an emergency
so um
bottom line just signed on with them my
base or my guaranteed is going to be 90
000.
based on commission i think i can take
home gross about 163
000 a year good um yeah i can pick up
extra shifts so i'm really
like i said three years we're really
hoping to go for this so
i've got um two loans one is 142
000 and that is a 7.9
interest rate the other one is 252 000
roughly and it's 6.8
yeah so i have 41 000 in savings
um no other debt just my student loans
so my question is
do i hit those interest rates pretty
hard with that savings or
on my minimum do i if i go snowball do i
pay
minimum on that 251 and how do i tackle
these things
yeah yeah now before we go there now are
you married i may have missed this
i am not no sorry okay so you're single
right now making 163
000 okay cool great um yeah so
you're gonna hit that snowball now i i
do want you to look into
refund because those interest rates are
high and splash financial
can i i do know for a fact that they
can't beat that rate
okay so now here's the thing you're
refined to lower your interest rate
not to lower your payments not the
throat not to
come any lower okay we're trying to save
you money on the loan
on the long run all right but i want you
to go ahead and line up your debt
snowball with those two loans
and then make the minimum payments on
both but then all your extra money
for these next three years you're
putting it on the on the slowest one on
the smallest one
yeah so throw the 41 at the one uh at
the 140
right and uh look at refinancing both of
them
with splash if you can because if you
can drop it one percent
that saves you four grand a year yeah
okay they're they're at about four and a
half right now dave
okay so well i mean if i don't know if
both these
loans are going to qualify how they're
structured but if
if you can qualify and get those rolled
in
i mean two percent will be a grand a
year that's very helpful here it doesn't
change the
whole equation but it changes it by two
months or something
so the what changed the whole equation
was your wake-up call
uh where you had that oh crap moment and
you said i'm going to get in attack mode
and you went to warrior mode you pushed
warrior button on it
very good good for you and um
yeah and you know the good news about
veterinarian medicine is is that you can
make that kind of money
yeah and so you can clean this up very
quickly if you will if you're willing to
work as hard as you're willing to work
and as much as you're willing to work
getting all that ot and jacking that
jacking up there so yeah you've got the
solution
you know you need 400 000 and you can
make that in
you know your great income in three
years and knock it out
plus or minus interest rates plus or
minus what order of attack but
uh i would get the interest rates down
with splash like anthony suggested
and i would attack the smallest one
first and use the 40 000 bucks to do
that
you know hold a grand back for your baby
step one and then uh just lean in
and all you're gonna see are animals for
the next three years not people
not people except for the animals the
animals people that bring the animals in
but other than that you're gonna be
working
absolutely so um not dating you're
working
well now you just got to meddling but
yeah
you can go on a date if you want to go
on a date okay see you
as long as you're working as long as
she's not paying for it she's not paying
for it that's right she's going to where
she's working
yeah so but that's great you're doing
really good you've got a great
attitude about it you've got a uh a
sense of awareness
uh and uh you faced the reality you
looked at
looked the monster in the eyes and said
i'm gonna kill you we got this yeah yeah
i'm proud of you and all jokes aside
dave i hear discipline in in her voice
yeah
she's she's like okay tomorrow getting a
dvm
is almost in many cases it's harder than
becoming md
wow well think about it you have to
study several species yes
and md only has to study one yes so i
mean
it's serious it's real serious degree
and
um dumb people don't get them uh so it's
uh
uh yeah it's powerful i'm proud of you
good job jessica
all right open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five so what i can't figure
out is how
you get the reputation that if you're
here
that there's niceness on the show well i
mean
dave i think i i think what people are
saying anthony's not nice he just got a
little more swag than dave and so the
swag comes off cool
cool's come off nice you know your uncle
dave i'm nephew anthony that's what it
is
that's what it is you're uncle dave i'm
not i'm not sure what he just said
i think i just got insulted but i'm not
sure no not at all
not at all it's called the ramsay show
now so you know we have
you're the vet you're the seasoned i'm
the i'm i'm the rookie i'm i'm
i'm coming in just helping people
understand yeah yeah
you know feeling the nice shoes hey
somebody's got to be nice i don't hang
up on people on my show you don't have
people on your show
there's that yo that was a good clap
that's a good one
there's some detail that we need